you're watching Al Jazeera and Rob
Matheson and Doha we're bringing you
some breaking news out of Pakistan
Pakistan's former prime minister Imran
Khan is said to have been shot he's
leading a protest March from Lahore to
Islamabad demanding snap elections it
comes after he was banned for five years
for running from political office Kamal
Haider is joining us live on the phone
Kamal what more do we know about what's
been happening
[Music]
we have received Convoy was moving out
of the town of he was
a few kilometers from there when sharks
were fired at his container in which he
of course had been addressing those
large rallies now according to the
reports that we know so far he's been
shot in the foot uh a few other senior
leaders of the Pakistan city in South
African have also received uh bullet
wounds or injuries and one conformed
death we are trying to find out what
happened as to who was killed in this
but then then
however there are unconformed reports
we are trying to get it
unfortunately we have people have lost
our uh phone signal to Kamal Haider
there
um understandably of course that things
could be very difficult there and
Communications may be uh awkward that
may be affecting the lines that we can
get out of park out of the region at the
moment I understand we can go to a
spokesman uh for Imran Khan
um if you're on the line sir can you
tell me if you what you know about what
has happened
well I just heard come out I think you
know because I was I spoke to him
earlier than I you know now and you know
we share some information uh he's
correct you know he's been shot in the
foot and uh he's in stable condition you
know at least one person is confirmed
dead there are some who are injured but
you're making further inquiries you know
and I think I should be able to talk to
you in Greater detail in the next half
an hour to one hour like this I must say
you know that this is we were dreading
this we we expected the passions
government you know the Posh is
conglomerate you know which is ruling
Pakistan today the bunch of criminals
the cabal of criminals they we knew they
were going to resort to this and they
have resorts to this but this does not
mean that our struggles
it does not mean that our struggle is
going to end here we will continue
marching to Islamabad we shall not not
not let this go
so let me ask you because you are making
you're making the application forgive me
for interrupting you but you're making
allegations against uh individuals and
groups here is there any evidence that
you have to suggest that you know who it
was that pulled the triggers at this
moment in time at this moment in time no
I cannot punish the evidence but you
know exactly what happens you know we
appreciate you sharing with the media in
short course of time
do you is there any indication that this
you said before that there was this was
something that you were dreading was
there any evidence to suggest that
something like this might happen that
you have received in the past weeks or
months
well we we we knew exactly how these
people you know are uh you know sitting
scared you know in the in their tacos
you know and we knew that they're going
to come out the interior Minister has
been threatening Iran Khan publicly on
television you can you can go back and
watch the last seven days you know he's
been not fully affecting Pakistan that
you should make an example of him other
other members of the other members of
the government have also been tracking
Iran so that they will make an example
of this March and that they would not
make this go to Islamabad they'll come
to Islamabad we we have we have enough
evidence with Arsenal and in due course
of time we said we would like to share
it with but we have absolutely no doubt
in our minds that this is the cabal of
criminals who ruled Pakistan today that
they are resorted to the 16 measure but
this is not going to deter us we shall
not be deterred by these criminal
tactics yes I should point out to our
viewers who are just joining us I'm
speaking to a spokesman on who's
speaking on behalf of Imran Khan we are
very early into this incident there is
no evidence yet to suggest who it was
that has carried out this attack we're
still and not clear exactly who has been
injured and what injuries have been uh
inflicted on people this is still
um materializing in front of us we
understand that Imran Khan was leading a
protest from I believe Lahore to
Islamabad had been demanding uh snap
elections I believe we can go back to
our correspondent Kamal Haider Kamal
this is going to cause a tremendous
amount of tension within the country
absolutely the country was already dense
with tens of thousands of policemen who
were in Islamabad and anticipation that
Imran Khan's March would be coming to
Islamabad so that of course uh uh would
now this particular incident would add
more tension his party workers are angry
they obviously will blame the government
although it is too early to know exactly
what happened who was involved but Imran
Khan had already said we had spoken to
him recently he said that despite all
the threats to his life that he would
continue with this March no matter what
happened so it will be important to see
whether there's going to be a change of
tactics but obviously his party
supporters and people across the country
are going to protest this because he
does enjoy tremendous support across the
country and obviously the
would be pointing fingers at the
government had been a war of words
between the government and his party
um and so it will be important to see
exactly how the government reacted as
well
um uh at the moment we do know that he
was with the way uh in his vehicle
and that he had indeed received a bullet
wound to his legs we are also told that
a couple of other leaders also are
injured so far there are reports that
one person has been killed reports are
still filtering in and we of course will
update you when we have more on this
particular story yes as you've been
talking to us come out we've been
watching some pictures here which I
believe will be taken from one of the
local TV networks in Pakistan which
appear to show uh
what has been happening around this
particular incident it does look very
confused it appears to be a picture I
think on the right hand side of
um Imran Khan being moved into a a dark
car we're only seeing the back of the
gentleman's head so I can't be con
confident that that is a mankind Kamal
you were making the point of course that
it is going to be vital now to see how
the government reacts to this because as
far as Imam Khan's followers are
concerned they believe they know exactly
who was responsible for this but there
is no evidence yet about who it was that
pulled that trigger as you say it's what
what does the government do next is what
many people are going to be asking
absolutely in the past few days there's
been warnings from the ruling Coalition
that Imran Khan's March was going to be
uh bloody because there were accusations
that some of his supporters might be
coming armed to Islamabad for that
protest the government also asking the
police chief for the parking for live
ammunition to be supplied to the police
um because of that right now obviously
it is going to be important to see as
you mentioned how the government reacts
how Imran Khan
supported react he has enjoyed a
tremendous support across the country it
is likely to lead to protests across the
country uh people of course are still
finding out but many people would be in
a State of Shock given the fact that
Pakistani politics has become a trans
Affair Imran Khan has been demanding
being Club elections he's won the
by-election the government on the other
hand saying that they will continue to
rule for another 10 months which is when
they complete their tenure so a lot of
tension and All Eyes Of course will be
now on the reaction to this particular
attack although as you mentioned the
suspicion from the Pakistan Tarik
himself would be that the government is
involved and the government obviously
will have to come clean on this by uh
taking action to point out exactly what
happened uh who was involved in this
attack uh what kind of weapon was used
in the attack uh the good news of course
at the moment is that Imran Khan has
indeed uh
um been injured but not critically and
he of course according to his uh one of
his advisors that I was with a little
while ago or he have got his name
meaning the government the government
has not yet reacted the interior
Ministry is likely to issue a statement
so indeed an evolving situation but a
volatile situation existing here in
Pakistan at the moment Kamal if you
could just for our viewers who perhaps
are not following the um the the state
of politics in Pakistan what has led up
to the this split if you like between
Imran Khan and the government can you
just fill us in a little bit of the
background just give us an idea of how
the tensions Rose between uh Rose
against Imran Khan
well if you remember it was in April
that the vote of no confidence was moved
by a combined Coalition of a 13 parties
uh that succeeded in acting him from
Parliament uh after that
um the government decided to hold by
elections on some of the seats where
from where Imran Khan's party members
had resigned and
Imran Khan then contesting those
elections at the sole candidates and
sweeping the poles he of course had been
saying that the ruling correlation does
not have the Mandate that the people of
Pakistan have come out strongly in his
favor uh given the fact that it won
those by-election by a wide margin
indeed so the friction between the two
the government saying that it will
complete the senior that it will not
Buckle under pressure from Imran Khan
who of course was leading this March
which started in Lahore and of course
the destination being Islamabad so
indeed it will be important to see
whether there is some sort of uh talks
to try to reduce tensions if they
um if that will lead to normalizing the
situation but at the moment there is one
apprehension that is supported might
come out angry supporters across the
country which would create more
complications for the government which
was focusing more on the containment of
this March as far as Islamabad was
concerned but if the protests are
widespread then the government of course
will have a new challenge to deal with
yes for viewers who are just joining us
here on Al Jazeera Imran Khan the former
Pakistani prime minister has reportedly
been injured in a shooting attack
targeting his supporters as they March
in the capital Islamabad apparently
unidentified government have opened fire
on the vehicle counting Mr Khan as it
passed through wazirabad and Pakistan's
Dawn newspaper has been reporting that
we're watching pictures of the at the
moment of the the chaos that surrounding
the the seconds just immediately after
uh the the shooting
um Imran Kamal we are of course familiar
with seeing scenes of uh violence and
scenes of protest uh on the streets in
Pakistan particularly surrounding Imran
Khan he is a very charismatic character
he is somebody who has drawn tens of
thousands of supporters and whilst we
absolutely do not know at this stage who
it might have been who has pulled the
trigger in this event a lot of Suspicion
will be as we were talking about earlier
on the elements of the government who
are concerned about the influence that
Imran Khan may have in the country
indeed his popularity has surprised many
because before the vote of confidence
there was a campaign by the opposition
parties against inflation the
deteriorating economic conditions which
they play blamed on Imran Khan however
the situation has worsened further
inflation is
skyrocketed and that of course has led
to the more popularity for Imran Khan uh
the people of course now realizing that
things were better under his tenure and
that the new government which
ousted him was unable to deliver on its
promises so indeed the Imran Khan has
become a real challenge this is a
one-man party against the Coalition of
13 political parties which have formed
the government in Islamabad and that too
after one of the Coalition partners of
Imran Khan's party uh switched sides and
went to the opposition so indeed
political turmoil oil expected Pakistan
of course has been reeling from
political uncertainty and stability and
that of course is also plaguing the
economy and of course there have been
warnings that this is now Beyond Imran
Khan that the people are fed up and that
some people have even been warning that
Pakistan may be heading uh in the same
situation that Sri Lanka saw with a
matchup rising from the people so indeed
patents and typical times uh as far as
Pakistan's political uh scene is
concerned but uh obviously Imran Khan's
party will be blaming the government uh
both sides do not spare any opportunity
to blame each other and this of course
will become more intense after this
particular incident yes and I would
imagine that as Imran Khan's spokesman
was was telling us before they have had
they say that they have been very
concerned and that this kind of thing
might happen and there he was suggesting
that they had evidence that there was uh
that something might occur along these
lines there are going to be questions of
course asked about the level of security
surrounding Imran Khan given had the
potential for something like this to
happen
to carrying out this act given the fact
that Imran Khan's uh Convoy had been
moving to a street people have been
coming out on the rooftop that security
concern was definitely very high on the
minds of some of which advisors but
Imran Khan had said recently that his
protest will be peaceful he has held a
large protests before that were peaceful
however the government had been warning
that they have a certain intelligence
reports that this could be a violent uh
protest by Imran Khan so the incident of
course will now put the government on a
backboard the Pakistani prime minister
has just come back from China and it
will be important to see how he reacts
how other political party ahead will
react but the war of words certainly
intensifying uh between the ruling
Coalition and Imran Khan's party and his
support guys yeah man come on that is
the way that the government handles this
is going to be key isn't it they're
going to have to walk a very fine line
because as you say the Imran Khan
supporters are immediately going to be
placing blame on members of the
government but of course we have no
evidence yet to suggest that that
connection can be made this is going to
be an extremely difficult time for the
government as well
absolutely it will be a difficult time
for the government
because of the high friction between
these political parties uh and very
tense times for Pakistan's political
stability
um the Pakistani rupee has no dive of
the ruling Coalition brought in a new
Finance Minister hoping to rectify the
situation saying that the new Finance
Minister had a lot of experience that it
was going to be able to succeed in
stabilizing the economy so there are
several other factors which of course at
the moment are favoring Imran Khan and
that is the shift in public opinion and
that was quite manifest from the fact
that he had a overwhelming victory in
all those by-election despite the fact
that the government had not accepted the
resignations of some of his party
members from Parliament despite the
facts the that the Pakistan Cherry can
shop which is Imran Khan's party
attended resignations and mosque but the
government decided to hold elections
only on some of those constituenties
by-elections and that was also a move in
order to muster their support within
Parliament to give them the simple
majority in case the smaller parties
decided to quit the Coalition so that of
course has now failed
um and the political deadlock of course
has now reached a new height of tension
between these political groups and
obviously that political instability is
now also factoring into Pakistan's
economic stability
Kamal just for viewers who are joining
us give us an update if you would on
what you know about what has happened
today Imran Khan former Pakistani prime
minister reportedly been injured in a
shooting attack what more details do you
have at the moment
well uh
joining him they are moving at a very
slow pace we were with Imran Khan on the
container it is moving its nail-based
because tens of thousands of people come
to listen to his speeches then they walk
alongside the container as it makes its
way forward towards Islamabad although
he is still almost a week away from
Islamabad giving their speed and that of
course shows that Imran Khan's position
that he was on that container along with
his leaders when shots were fired at the
container and the target obviously was
the leadership that is standing on top
of the container and full view of the
public there are no security
Arrangements like bulletproof glass
um Imran Khan of course has been
traveling in this container which is on
the top of talk with generators it's a
soft target it is not an armored vehicle
in any way and once these shots were
fired
um he was then evacuated into his uh
um Toyota vehicle the black vehicle that
you see in most of the footages they
were taken by his personal bodyguards
who are with him all the time he was put
in that vehicle and taken away but we're
also told that a few other key ministers
who served in the Imran Khan government
have also received injuries and we're
trying to find out more uh but because
of the jamming that is going on around
the container because there's also the
threat of Bomb Blast and that's why it
is difficult to get through to the
container and to talk to people who were
witnesses to this particular incident
come out for now thank you very much
indeed for bringing us up to date for
View who are just joining us Imran Khan
the former Pakistani prime minister
reportedly been injured in a shooting
attack on identifying the gunman or
gunman we don't know yet who is
responsible for this said to have opened
fire on a vehicle carrying Mr Khan as it
passed through azirabad or Assad Ramen
Khan is a political analyst he's in
Lahore he's with us now so thank you
very much indeed for being with us what
kind of an impact do you think this is
going this is going to have on
the tension in that is going on in
Pakistan right now
well thank you for having me there is a
fear that what we're seeing over the
past several months uh post the vote of
no confidence which removed Mr Khan from
power that sequence of events will allow
further gain momentum in terms of uh
instability in terms of a lot more fear
and political uncertainty as regards the
uh next year's elections Mr Khan's
principal concern was that general
elections should be called as soon as
possible and Pakistan has a disturbing
history of prime ministerial candidates
from
2007 in terms of their assassinations
this latest attempt on Mr Khan's life
throws those concerns into a stark
relief the core issue remaining that if
there is a majority mandate I.E Mr
Khan's party Remains the most popular
and is the largest party in the assembly
that should be respected and general
elections might act as a as a release
for that sort of that sort of pressure
or that sort of uncertainty
we've been hearing from our
correspondent and also from a spokesman
for Imam Khan uh both uh saying that it
is very likely that the supporters of
Imran Khan are immediately going to
point fingers
um at the government how do you think
the government should react to this in a
way that will not inflame the tension
that exists
well I think the very first thing the
government can do is to authorize a free
and independent investigation but here
if the key element is that the people
who are commencing those investigations
have to be entirely independent of the
government which is a tough ask the the
roots of the issue remains that the
government is widely perceived to be
suppressing what is the majority mandate
and is suppressing the electoral process
this is a coalition of 11 incredibly
disparate parties that did not arrive
fresh after a general election and the
question that that is being asked again
and again is that if we are a
parliamentary system if this is to be a
civilian government then let the
electoral process continue let the
country go to general elections and what
we are seeing in terms of the Public's
loss of faith I fear is going to be
exacerbated by today's assassination
attempt it would be best if the
government decides to meet Mr Khan
halfway announcing action schedules
authorizes an independent inquiry into
this investigation and pushes on
just very briefly if the government is
not able to do something that will
satisfy the supporters of Imran Khan
what do you think they're going to do
well what has been heartening thus far
is that Mr Khan and this is something
that is in fact a political consensus
across the board whether government or
opposition everybody has been insisting
that the protests need to be peaceful
the government instead engaged in an
incredibly violent set of of counter
operations earlier in May when Mr Khan
decided to take this long march out the
first time it is urged not only by Civil
Society by the lawyers Community by by
analysts in general
that things remain safe secure and what
Mr Khan has been insisting again and
again that they do not want violence
um I think it would be best that the PTI
leadership the PTI being Mr Khan's party
stresses that once more
we understand that uh former prime
minister Imran Khan has been taken to
Lahore Hospital one would imagine uh for
treatment we're still finding out trying
to find out more details about what is
happening there we understand also that
there are two or three other people
who've been caught up in this we're not
clear on the level of injuries that they
have received
um so thank you very much indeed Assad
Khan for talking to us he was a
political analyst he was talking to us
from Lahore I want to bring in arifa
Noor she's a political analyst and a
columnist for Dawn she is in Islamabad
and she's with us live via Skype thank
you for being with us
um was it perhaps given the rhetoric
that we have heard over the last several
months between Imran Khan's supporters
himself and the government was it
perhaps inevitable that something like
this may happen
uh thank you it's uh it's always hard to
say whether something like this would be
inevitable I think the kind of history
that Pakistan has seen we would always
um I think you know like to assume or
hope that the violence is behind us but
obviously given our history considering
that we have already lost more than one
prime minister one former one actor you
know in position two violence such as
this it doesn't come as that huge a
surprise I would say but I don't think
that when people spoke about violence
and often obviously a lot of people were
predicting that especially from the
government side that Imran Khan's March
would lead to violence or some kind of
Bloodshed that the attack would actually
take place on Imran Khan himself
the Imran Khan and others have been
stressing that whatever protests were
taking place should be peaceful given
that this has happened do you think that
they're going to continue to be peaceful
or is the tone of what we're seeing on
the streets of Pakistan going to change
um well obviously you know the the
environment has been very dense and
while the government has you know kept
saying that this will become bloody or
there will be Bloodshed and that you
know the Pakistan Teri kins happening
want that because they think they would
add to the pressure the signals from PTI
were different in that sense Imran Khan
himself spoke about whether this would
be a soft Revolution or a bloody one in
a tweet but so far they're uh you know
disorganization aside their Long March
had been a pretty uh peaceful but
obviously what has happened today is a
very different and we you know as I said
nobody expected it to be like this to
have a gunshots fired at a former prime
minister considering they just back in
2006 we lost a very popular leader to
this kind of violence right now there is
an immediate reaction from the
supporters of Pakistan
and it it is you know an aggressive
reaction but hopefully once the
leadership recovers from the shop
because at the moment it seems as if
they're all rushing to look or where uh
the former prime minister has been taken
for a treatment they will try and keep
their supporters calm and prevent the
kind of violence that broke out in
Pakistan when uh was assassinated back
in 2007. it is going to put the
government in a very difficult position
isn't it because even let's for the sake
of argument say the government had
nothing to do with this at all it is
going to be very difficult for the
government to try to persuade people
that it was not connected with the with
what has happened today if indeed that
is the case
yes I think that the immediate uh that's
very obvious at the moment of course we
don't know at the moment who has been
injured how significant or serious the
injuries to Imran Khan himself are there
are talks there is talk already of at
least one person having been injured
very badly so obviously that is going to
be the immediate concern but beyond it
if you look at the political situation
the government which is already on the
defensive and it's on the defensive
party of course because of the
popularity of Imran Khan then recently
we've had the death of a journalist and
that you know whenever an event like
that takes place there is a lot of
pressure on the government and
especially because of the circumstances
in which he left the country
um everybody you know there were cases
that were registered against him and
we've had some very extraordinary
reactions to his death and the attacker
Imran Khan is just going to up the
pressure the up the pressure pressure on
uh the the government and to some extent
on the military as well let's see but I
don't think that this is going to be a
case of where just only the government
will feel the pressure I think the
military leadership will also uh feel it
this is you were talking there uh just a
few seconds ago we were seeing some
pictures of uh of coming from Pakistan
TV in fact the pictures are on screen
now showing a a red circle in which
there appears to be a man wearing a
black jacket and what appear holding
what appears to be a pistol in his right
hand he's being grabbed by a man in a
Red Top Shot immediately behind him that
possibly could be a picture of one of
the attackers we have no evidence to
suggest that or to back that up at the
moment but as I say these are pictures
that are coming out from Pakistan TV but
arifa Noor political analyst and
columnist for Don we appreciate you
being with us on Al Jazeera thank you
very much indeed
well earlier I spoke with Imran Khan's
spokesperson and he says this attack
will not stop their March towards the
capital
you share some information uh he's
correct you know he's been shot in the
foot and he's in stable condition you
know at least one person is confirmed
dead there are some who are injured but
we're making further inquiries you know
and I think I should be able to talk to
you in Greater detail in the next half
an hour to one hour but this I must say
you know that this is we were dreading
this we we expected the cautious
government you know the cautious
conglomerate you know which is ruling
Pakistan today the bunch of criminals
the cabal of criminals they we knew they
were going to resort to this and they
have resorts to this it does not mean
that our struggle is going to end here
we will continue marching to Islamabad
we shall not not not let this go so let
me ask you because you are making you're
making the application forgive me for
interrupting you but you're making
allegations against uh individuals and
groups here is there any evidence that
you have to suggest that you know who it
was that pulled the trigger at this
moment in time at this moment in time no
I cannot punish the evidence but you
know exactly what happens you know we
apprecially sharing with the media in
short course of time
do you is there any indication that this
you said before that there was this was
something that you were dreading was
there any evidence to suggest that
something like this might happen that
you have received in the past weeks or
months well we we we knew exactly how
these people so are you know sitting
scared you know in the in the cocoons
you know and we knew that they're going
to come out the interior Minister has
been threatening Imran Khan publicly on
television you can you can go back and
watch the last seven days you know he's
the most fully expecting Pakistan that
you should make an example of him other
other members of the other members of
the government have also been practicing
Imran so that they will make an example
of dispatch and that they would not make
this go to Islamabad they'll come to
Islamabad we we have we have enough
evidence with us you know and in due
course of time we said we would like to
share it with but we have absolutely no
doubt in our minds that this is the
cabal of criminal to rule Pakistan today
that they have resorted to the 16
measure but this is not going to deter
us we shall not be deterred by these
criminal tactics
okay you can go back to our
correspondent cabal Haider who's talking
to us on the phone Kamal it's quite
clear from what Imran Khan's spokesman
is saying there that they are on they
know exactly who was behind this attack
but of course we're in the early stages
of this there is no evidence to suggest
who it was that pulled the Checker or
who may have carried out the attack
nevertheless this is simply going to add
to the tension that we have been seeing
in Pakistan growing over the last weeks
and months
indeed that Jensen has been growing in
the backdrop of uh censorship Imran the
beaches are being censored by the local
TV uh also the fact that many
journalists have left Pakistan saying
that they were the threat to their life
from the government's key journalists
three four journalists in just one week
alone have left Pakistan uh there's a
media clamped down and now this
particular incident so suspicions of
course would be high that uh somebody
from the ruling Coalition was involved
but as you very rightly said it is too
early uh to point fingers uh his party
members of course are convinced that
this was orchestrated
um by elements within the government the
interior Minister uh has been
threatening he of course had said that
he suspects that he Imran Khan's March
would end in a bloody way because
there were weapons that were being
smuggled so far no concrete evidence
given by the government to that effect
Imran Khan has held large protests
within the country most of them have
been peaceful he's always said that he
plays by the book and by the
Constitution and had assured everybody
that this was a peace March or a March
of freedom in Pakistan that women and
children and we saw that ourselves that
women and children entire families have
been participating in this protest March
which of course has been grinding its
way to Islamabad in the meantime
Islamabad has the government has
requisitioned the services of tens of
thousands of security Personnel right
now Islamabad looks more like a drive
course with shipping containers that
have been put on the side of the roads
in order to block access to Islamabad to
prevent Imran Khan's March from entering
the city so this particular incident uh
is not going to be taken lightly by his
supporters who are in large numbers
across the country and there may be a
reaction on the street with protists
breaking out across the country uh given
the fact that he's one of the most
popular leaders in Pakistan today we had
spoken to him earlier a few days ago we
were on the same container with Imran
Khan they were obviously security
concerns but Imran Khan said uh to us
that he was not worried about the
consequences that this was a March of
effort and for freedom and through
democracy and Pakistan he's been very
critical of the government and he was
going to make some more relations today
he's been singling out the government in
his speeches and the government on the
other hand has been singling out Imran
Khan
for uh trying to Blackmail them so
indeed a very volatile political
situation in Pakistan and this incident
is likely to add to the temperature
life for us in Islam about on the phone
Kamal thank you very much indeed I'm
joined Now by Al jazeera's Osama bin
Javed who's covered Pakistan extensively
for us we heard Imran Khan's spokesman
there saying that as far as they were
concerned this March was going to
continue there was nothing that was
going to stop it and yet as uh Kamal was
just telling us
that are shipping containers which are
blocking the roads in Islamabad that
seems as though given what has happened
today there is going to be there has to
be almost a tension point when that
March even when that March makes its way
to Islamabad this is going to be a very
very tense time
another tense time in Pakistan's
volatile political last few years Imran
Khan's insisted that he is going to go
ahead with this March no matter what and
he said that and he's warned that this
could be a blood shed ridden March if
the government does not give him what he
wants which is a date for early
elections which so far the government
has rejected to the point of what the
containers look like every single time
in this government or whether Imran Khan
was in power when there is a March when
there is a political movement going
towards Islamabad that is the modus
operandi of the security establishment
they block the roads they bring in
shipping containers the red zone is
sealed and nobody's allowed to enter now
there is a there's also a court case
underway where Imran Khan is saying that
we should be given the right we have the
right to protest we should be given
space in Islamabad and the government
has resisted so far citing that the last
time they gave him space he attacked the
Red Zone and there were scuffles with
the government and lots of people were
injured
um as we're speaking now I'm looking at
the tweet from the former uh Minister
for human rights who says that
essentially accusing the current
interior minister of Pakistan uh because
he threatened and in her words
threatened to murder Imran Khan and
today we saw him attempt that he should
be arrested on attempted murder that's
what she says and Shri mazari further
says the string pullers The
Establishment will also be held
responsible by the nation for this so
you see that already there are fingers
being pointed at not just the government
but also the military establishment of
Pakistan which for years had been
accused of backing Imran Khan remember
the people who are in power now accused
Imran Khan of riding on the back of
Pakistan's powerful military to win
those elections and now Imran Khan has
fallen out of favor he's called the
names so much so that the director
general of Pakistan's Intelligence
Agency for the first time in 70 years of
Pakistan's history had to come out on TV
and saying they have no role in politics
they are not backing any horse in this
and people should use their Democratic
rights according to the Constitution of
Pakistan so again this background is
important because it shows you how
volatile the situation has been in the
last few weeks if not the last few
months when Imran Khan was ousted with a
vote of no confidence or some say with
me because we have Shireen Masari who is
the senior vice president of Imran
Khan's own self party and she's with us
on the phone Mum thank you very much
indeed for being with us on Al Jazeera
just first can I ask you do you know any
more about what has happened today
well what we know now is that um there
was this man fiery who fired directly at
Imran Khan from the crowd one of our
workers pushed his gun downward one of
our ideas
ex-governor Imran Ismail is injured
another worker who was on the container
Russia was injured another gentleman by
the name of Mr chatta's India so uh
obviously this is the last desperate
attempt to try and stop the Long March
and this is nothing new
um unfortunately we've now have an
interior Minister who has already got
blood on his hands from previous cases
and he for the last week has been
directly actually using the work that
she's going to get him on
so which is why I have stated that he
his public statements have been
threatening to murder Imran Khan and
this was an attempt today but not just
that we know that in Pakistan's history
the military The Establishment whenever
political leaders fall out for them
murders happened there's lakit Ali Khan
then more most recently of course we
have seen Ben Aziz bhutto's mother still
unresolved and this was an attempt now
at Imran Khan's life so unfortunately
our history
shows that
leaders who stand and fight for
independence or will not accept dick
that are punished in a most fatal manner
do you think that it is important now
for leading supporters of Imran Khan
like yourself to encourage the the
crowds that we have seen the tens of
thousands of supporters who've come out
to support Imran Khan in the past to
stay calm in this incidence to try to
avoid an explosion of violence akin to
what we have seen before on the streets
of Pakistan
if you recall on the 25th of May when
Imran Khan had asked for the March and
people came out we were absolutely
peaceful we never carry weapons because
our protests always include families and
it was the this government backed by The
Establishment that Unleashed a violence
against us against this Imran Khan has a
consistently stated that our March is
peaceful I was alongside except for the
last two days with the Mahar March and
if we had children and families coming
up
not that it's a group of men just
protesting it's the nation that has
risen and Imran Khan is the one who has
kept the temperature of the people
controlled people are angry they're
angry at the way the establishment is
behaved the press conference that was
conducted
they're angry at the bunch of peace that
the establishment imposed on the country
so we people are very very angry and
this attempt to kill Imran Khan is going
to create more anger and we have to time
contain it but frankly the
are not going to act sensibly then I am
afraid how long will people be able to
control their temper I don't know
already
across Pakistan and uh with the American
injured we don't see who is going to
control them and how many people uh of
the country will The Establishment uh
fire upon or kill this is not acceptable
the first thing that we demanded is
immediately resigned and his name should
be put as attempted murder
please stay with me because we have our
correspondent Osama bin Javed in Doha
with us he's covered Pakistan
extensively I what do you have to miss
Missouri uh just a quick note on what
your uh former prime minister Imran Khan
had said that the revolution is coming
in Pakistan through Ballot or Bloodshed
are those words in any way connected to
what we're seeing on the streets today
and what is going to be your future
course of action is the March going to
continue as Rob said are you going to
ask people for calm because we're
already seeing pictures where policemen
have been attacked in the streets of
Pakistan
we always won't come
to a certain point it's difficult to
control an angry mob as everybody knows
and it is up to the state to ensure that
they don't do anything Reckless now in
terms of attacking protesters in terms
of firing on protesters that was not the
way to go about it
um this sort of uh you know mindset
tunnel vision of the establishment has
causes a lot of damage in Pakistan and
the second thing is that I'm sure
tonight will there will be a discussion
on the March but our goal will remain
and how the March continues towards
Islamabad we will decide because my my
own fear is that people may reach
Islamabad before the leadership even
decides people are so angry right now
and
I said before this is nothing new in
Pakistan whenever a populist leader who
catches the nation's fantasy and
Promises them uh justice and freedom uh
that that leader is not acceptable to
the powers that be the establishment and
this is the reality
action to a populist movement but
extremely foolish and short-sighted
because it does damage to the country
nothing else
thank you very much indeed for joining
for joining us
um that was Shireen Masari a senior vice
president of Imran Khan's party she's
been talking to us on the phone on the
day that uh
the Imran Khan the former Pakistani
prime minister has reportedly been
injured in a shooting attack targeting
his supporters as they marched on the
capital Islamabad we're told that
unidentified gunman opened fire on the
vehicle carrying Mr Khan as it passed
through wasidibad that was according to
Pakistan's Dawn newspaper we've also
been seeing footage from local
television in Pakistan which has been
showing us the moments just after Imran
Khan was shot we understand he was shot
in the foot we are going to have more
details on this in later bulletins